todos los grupos funcionales en este
vídeo tienen un carbono unido con un
doble enlace a un oxígeno a eso le
llamamos carbón y lo aquí tenemos un
carbón y lo carbón y lo y aquí tenemos
otro
el primer grupo funcional es un aldehído
una de ido tiene un grupo r de un lado
del carbón y lo y del otro lado un
hidrógeno como ejemplo tenemos este
compuesto
aquí tenemos nuestro carbón y lo y de
este lado tenemos un hidrógeno unido
directamente a este carbono en el carbón
y lo del lado izquierdo tenemos un grupo
r
y digamos que el carbono en el carbón y
lo es el carbono 1 este sería el carbono
2 carbono 3 y carbono 4 tenemos un
aldehído de 4 carbonos y como nombramos
a un aldehído de 4 carbonos bueno
sabemos que aún al cano de 4 carbonos se
le llama butano 1 2 3 y 4 butano
entonces para un aldehído simplemente
agregamos la terminación al es decir si
quitamos la o de butano y agregamos la
terminación al el nombre para esta
molécula es votan al votan al ahora
veamos la acetona un acetona tiene un
grupo r en ambos lados del carbón y lo
en nuestro ejemplo de la derecha
necesitamos numerar los carbonos y dar
al carbón hilo el número más pequeño
posible entonces empezamos por el lado
izquierdo
este es el carbono 1 el carbono en el
carbón y lo es el carbono 2
este es el carbono 3 carbono 4 y carbono
5 tenemos una acetona de 5 carbonos
recordemos que un alcano de 5 carbonos
dibujaré por aquí a esto se le llama
ventana ventana entonces una acetona
tiene la terminación o no así que sólo
quitamos la otra ventana y agregamos la
terminación on entonces tenemos ventana
venta none y también necesitamos indicar
la posición del carbón y lo en este caso
se encuentra en la posición dos así que
escribimos dos ventanas si por ejemplo
dibujamos otra molécula como penta non
pero esta vez ponemos el carbón hilo en
la posición 31 23 este compuesto sería 3
ventana que es diferente de la 2 ventana
por eso es importante indicar la
posición del carbón y lo para un
aldehído no es necesario indicar la
posición en el carbono 1 porque en
realidad es la única posición en la que
se puede encontrar observen que el
aldehído tiene este hidrógeno unido
directamente al carbono en el carbón
hilo mientras que en la acetona el grupo
carbón y lo es
unido a todos carbonos esa es la
diferencia entre una de ido y una se
toma a muchos estudiantes les cuesta
trabajo diferenciar entre una acetona y
un aldehído pero si buscan este
hidrógeno unido directamente al carbono
en el carbón y lo ese es un aldehído
ahora continuemos con el ácido
carboxílicos el ácido carboxílicos tiene
un grupo r de un lado del carbón hilo y
un h del otro lado al principio muchos
estudiantes piensan que este es un
alcohol pero no es un alcohol porque el
h está unido directamente al carbono en
el carbón y lo y eso cambia las
propiedades los ácidos carboxílicos
tienen propiedades diferentes a las de
los alcoholes como ejemplo para el ácido
carboxílicos que tenemos de la
derecho sabemos que el carbono en el
carbón y lo es el carbono 1 así que este
es el carbono 2 carbono 3 y carbono 4
tenemos un ácido carboxílicos de 4
carbonos entonces aún alcano de 4
carbonos se le llama butano y ahora solo
tenemos que agregar la palabra ácido y
la terminación oiko así que uno de los
nombres para este compuesto es ácido
butano y ccoo ácido
bután hoy ccoo y uno de los ácidos
carboxílicos más famosos sólo tiene dos
carbonos lo dibujaré rápidamente se le
llama ácido acético y lo encontramos en
el vinagre el vinagre es una solución
diluida de ácido acético en agua nuestro
siguiente grupo funcional es el allure o
de asilo o también llamado allure o de
ácido en química orgánica hablamos mucho
de los cloruros de asilo aquí tenemos
nuestro carbono unido con un doble
enlace a un oxígeno del lado izquierdo
tenemos un grupo r y del lado derecho
tenemos un cloro los saludos de asilo
provienen de ácidos carboxílicos en
nuestro ejemplo tenemos un carbón y lo
nuestro halógeno
todo esto es un grupo asilo así que este
es el cloruro de asilo aunque también se
le puede llamar cloruro de ácido nuestro
siguiente grupo funcional es el
anhídrido aquí tenemos nuestro carbón y
lo un grupo r y en lugar de un cloro
ahora tenemos todo esto del lado derecho
este es un anhídrido de ácido o
simplemente un anhídrido y también es un
derivado del ácido carboxílicos es decir
que podemos formar un anhídrido a partir
de un ácido carboxílicos y nuestro
ejemplo de la derecha es el anhídrido
acético nuestro siguiente grupo
funcional es un este también es un
derivado del ácido carboxílicos el ácido
carboxílicos tenía un hidrógeno justo
aquí
y ahora tenemos un grupo r así que
tenemos nuestro grupo carbón y lo un ere
y un grupo r en nuestro ejemplo aquí
tenemos un grupo estilo en lugar de un
hidrógeno si recordamos el ácido acético
lo dibujaré nuevamente
el ácido acético tiene un hidrógeno pero
como ahora tenemos un grupo de tilo
entonces estamos hablando de un este no
de un ácido carboxílicos y si queremos
nombrar al esther observen que tenemos
este grupo de tilo y luego tenemos esta
parte acetato así que este es el acetato
de etilo más adelante aprenderemos a
nombrar estos compuestos por ahora no es
tan importante pero es bueno que los
empiecen a conocer finalmente nuestro
último grupo funcional se llama amiga
aquí tenemos el grupo carbón hilo y
observen que hay un nitrógeno unido
directamente al carbono en el carbón y
lo y tenemos un par de electrones libres
en el nitrógeno
estos grupos r también pueden ser
hidrógenos o grupos al kilo existen
muchos ejemplos de amigas en este
ejemplo el carbono en el carbón y lo es
el número 1 así que este sería el
carbono 2 3
y 4 esta es una vida de 4 carbonos y se
llama bután amiga lo escribiré bután
amiga